christmas is calling auf der oxford
street in london
die einkaufsmeile läutet die
weihnachtssaison ein für viele der
startschuss zum dekorieren aber welcher
schmuck ist dieses jahr besonders
angesagt
eines der großen trendthemen weihnachts
rock n roll gehört diesen winter nicht
nur auf die ohren sondern auch an den
baum
[Musik]
es dreht sich alles um rock'n'roll
glitzer funkeln und metallic für eine
dekadente party mit familie und freunden
wir waren fasziniert von den
verschiedenen materialien und wie viel
spaß man mit dem thema haben kann
mitsamt und pailletten werden auch die
traditionellen weihnachts strümpfe teil
der edel rock deko silber und gold aber
vor allem schwarz ist besonders angesagt
hauptsache es rockt bei diesem trend
mitzumachen das lässt sich auch
superstar trends nicht nehmen
wichtig für rock'n'roll
weihnachtslichter sind die farben
ich glaube wir haben uns viele jahre
nicht getraut den retro look mit bunten
lichtern zu kombinieren aber dieses jahr
ist die richtige zeit dafür
der dezente zurückhaltung langweilig
findet kann mit dem rock'n roll trennt
diese weihnachten nicht falsch liegen
weniger laut und knallig aber mindestens
genauso schillernd und ausgefallen ist
dieser besonders schmackhafte trend
[Musik]
dieses jahr sind wir vom thema essen
begeistert es gibt dem weihnachtsbaum
einen verspielten touch wir haben zum
beispiel popcorn erdbeerkörbchen bagels
oder salz und pfeffer weihnachtsschmuck
in großbritannien sind nahrungsmittel
als design trend schon länger zu
beobachten aber jetzt erobern sie auch
den weihnachtsbaum also nicht nur beim
weihnachtlichen festmahl sondern auch
bei der dekoration ist schlimm angesagt
die farbauswahl spielt dabei keine rolle
bunt und lecker muss der weihnachtsbaum
aussehen
[Musik]
ich liebe die avocado jeder liebt doch
avocado zu essen und ich denke als deko
ist sie ein nettes lustiges geschenk sie
ist schön und funkelt und sieht neben
dem anderen weihnachtsschmuck hübsch aus
wen das zur außergewöhnlich ist der kann
sich mit klassischer
weihnachtsdekoration ein gemütliches
zuhause zaubern ein wohlfühl ambiente
verspricht der trend mit dem schönen
namen midnight elegance
hier muss man aber einiges beachten
es geht darum ein luxuriöses zuhause zu
schaffen
mit kräftigen farben schönen oberflächen
metallelementen und glas so bringen sie
glanz und funkeln auf ihren tisch an
ihren weihnachtsbaum und in ihr ganzes
zu hause mit viel gold glas und blauer
wird diese festtafel ein hingucker
[Musik]
ganz im trend ist natürlich auch die
deko auf der oxford street mit fast 2000
weihnachtskugeln wird sie zum wahren
winterwunderland aber ist es nicht etwas
zu früh um die weihnachtsbeleuchtung
einzuschalten
es ist etwas früher aber hey weihnachten
is toll jeder liebt weihnachten also
warum nicht
ich denke es ist schön dass sie jetzt
schon die lichter anschalten das bringt
menschen zusammen es ist festlich und
weckt die vorfreude
es bringt alle in stimmung und erinnert
daran dass weihnachten vor der tür steht
die gesichter meiner kinder zu sehen wie
sie beim licht einschalten strahlen das
war toll für mich
und je früher die weihnachtszeit
eingeläutet wird desto länger kann man
sich in sachen dekoration schließlich
ausleben
[Musik]